women talk about something like empathy
and women are known to be more
empathetic than men but women don't care
about a man's struggle they hang out at
the finish line and they pick the winner
well i care about a man's trouble
i think a lot of women care about a
man's struggle like why wouldn't you but
if you see them
disintegrate becoming a loser because of
bad choices
because of choices because of lifestyle
because of whatever happens kevin from
sales is going to look like a better
option than bozo at home
am i right yes so you know yourself you
know you're not going to do that you
might [ __ ] up a little bit but you're
not going to do anything like that so
why don't you trust your girlfriend to
keep loving you i know but what you're
trying to do irene is you're trying to
take
your interpretation of the sexual
marketplace and you're trying to take
that and unplug it from your
firmware and plug it into rich cooper
and say i want you to see things my way
and men don't need to see things your
way men need to see things
their way they need to understand what
masculinity looks like and how to view
the sexual marketplace so they can get
better results and be admired by the
women that they want to be with